overseas now for the latest on the war
in Ukraine there has been new fighting
around the eastern city of bakmud and
Russia is claiming to have repelled a
large Ukrainian attack in the eastern
part of the country Ukrainian officials
declined to comment on all of it Deborah
patta has more now from the city of
harkiv
this is the video released by Russia's
Ministry of Defense claiming to show its
troops repelling a Ukrainian advance in
the Eastern Donetsk region we can't
verify this and Kiev has consistently
sent mixed signals perhaps a military
tactic in itself the latest being this a
video released over the weekend with the
tagline plans love silence Ukrainian
soldiers are seen urging operational
secrecy around any talk of a major and
much anticipated counter-offensive
across the border in Russia a new front
line has opened up anti-kremlin militia
fighting alongside Ukraine have stepped
up but tax in the bilgarad region the
daily hardships ukrainians have become
so accustomed to now being felt by
thousands of Russians who've taken
refuge in a temporary shelter
we're trying to be strong said every
because we have children who give us the
incentive to carry on and it is children
who are once again the center of yet
another Russian missile attack in the
early hours of Sunday morning this time
in the Ukrainian city of donipro
Rescuers working frantically overnight
brought the devastating news that at
least five children were injured in this
attack and a two-year-old girl was
killed as she slept with her mother
who's fighting for her own life in
hospitals
and president zelinski said over the
weekend at least 500 children have been
killed in the war to date children he
added who could have become Scholars
Deborah
that no tough to hear by 500 children
thank you so much
[Applause]